oh hey you guys are here already what do
you think about that open and it's
really a bad joke vibes dad jokes I
thought it was pretty slick a little
unexpected and a little treasure that's
what the h3 podcast is it's treasure
we're here to entertain the people you
know it's a tough world up there
lots of ups lots of downs we're here for
the downs and the ups we make the up so
let's be honest you go down we go up we
take them downs and we turn them into
ups mmm that's what I'm talking about
yeah yes yes yes yes today's episode is
sponsored by quip we have got some
incredible things playing here today now
right off the top of my head in it is
your two-year anniversary is it not of
working here yeah full-time yeah it is I
mean that's incredible how the time goes
by isn't it I can't believe you've been
here for two years and you've only just
been elevated to a salaried employee
yeah a long climb but finally made it no
time flew by it's crazy I can't believe
it's been two years no it is it is crazy
totally
you know what blew my mind even more
than that is just Zaka had been here for
a year right and I mean very young back
as great as green as a as a field after
spring and he's been here a year
although he's Goods Act this is just
gonna turn it to me complimenting Zach
wings anniversary zach has really
blossomed into a fine young man who
really rides the sound board all the way
to bailout but we're not here to
celebrate Zach Zach sultry voice thank
you no we're here to celebrate in who
has come such a long way
Ian who called emailed us who worked his
way into our heart and our minds and
into our collective souls and the intern
tell me about your two years of
experience here with us again
well the first
I didn't even appear on camera for like
six months right yeah it was like a
running gag right I forgot they never
showed your face not show right yeah I
remember we did when we did that live
show no one knew who I was like I was
selling merch and people were like wait
or like yeah the live show right things
have changed for you and now you're kind
of a bit of a celebrity do you feel that
way I mean you get recognized on the
streets you have women applying to date
you it's turned into oil thank you do
isn't it it's been an experience it's
been great though I've loved working
here it's been a lot of fun and then is
wearing a shirt with your face on it
Kauai is [ __ ] H fishery shop calm
support the nation that looks good I
don't know what's all the hate I mean
not hate but people aren't buying it
it's the least bought shirt people
people are buying it just happens to be
the least fun yeah it's like well people
bought like 500 of Elah and like 50 of
en but don't think that is a slight to
you and it just says no it's just a
little gate where that has a man I mean
it's no big deal it's shattered my
confidence and it's okay
yeah we know the true strength that is
in the end that's a boy and how do you
think that you've developed over the
years I mean how have you taken to
celebrity I don't know if I'd go that
far thing well you do get recognized on
the street by people that don't know who
you are so that is celebrity so what
maybe like I don't know like once a week
or something huh that's quite frankly
that wasn't until we had like million a
million busts up so damn yeah no I was
the other day when I said that I went to
the movies and the guy working there
came up to me and he said
are you Dan from the agent that's no
respect that you are Dan well I want to
cut to Benin is on this phone damn what
the [ __ ] we're doing a show here if it's
not phones texting Ian how did you did
you do that on purpose in you should do
that damn who you texting I I am
emailing somebody in relation to the
show okay oh alright I'll buy it is it D
somebody who's these somebody what now
I'm confused here PJ dear PJ now I'm
confused as oh is there something I
don't know oh I see no it's not PJ Papa
John yeah let's get fortunately it's not
we're here today right yeah let's stand
young sweet Ian who has been here for
two years full time I wanted to go out
of my way to get you a special something
in so I think I've done something that
you're gonna appreciate okay and I'm
very excited to share it with everybody
here I'm very excited so here we trust
that smile on your face I promise you're
gonna love this and everybody's gonna
love this no hang up so for your two
year anniversary I have this
announcement for you Oh sugar a the
church
Ethan wants to let you know something
man these never get easy things are
getting tough around the office Oh
unfortunately at this time and I know
it's tough around the holidays Ethan is
gonna have to let you go
unfortunately money's tight right now
you know oil prices around the world are
going crazy and it's affecting Ethan's
business and he's gonna have to let you
go I just can't afford to keep it around
anymore you've been a great employee a
great friend and he hates to do this to
you during the holiday season and he
thought the best way to let you know
that you're fired was through me Ian I
wish you the best you know a lot of
cliches kind of come into mind right now
when something like this is happening to
you you know when the chips are down you
know when one door closes another door
opens
mm-hmm you know when the going gets
tough the tough get going yeah it's not
how many times you fall down is how many
times get back up so I'm happier than
everybody we wish you the best and
you're more than capable it's not it's
not us it's you okay okay but happy
holidays and the best to you and your
family but there's time I'll be happy to
the mark McGrath give any a wonderful
employee we wish you the best in the
future sorry
well yeah it is bad news ultimately I
did spend $100 on that but that did
lessen the blow I think like you know he
he was very kind about it and do I have
to give the dollar back no you can come
you can keep the dollar as a severance
okay but do pack your [ __ ] up but this
is your last day here unfortunately okay
thanks mark what do you think about that
that's something special I can say you
know I'm I'm not too upset about it mark
really kind of you know assured me made
me feel comfortable he's got a real way
with words though I think he has a
talent for cameos that's what he was
said he made
and I I think that mark needs to be that
guy who just breaks bad news for people
for a hundred bucks he'll break any bad
news for you I think they really think
they're all like he's like he's H oh I'm
sorry but we are gonna have to lay yeah
yeah like do you think he knows that
people are goofing on him in this way
because he seems very sincere and
earnest with this I think I think he's
loving it I think he's loving this and I
hope that he's getting lots of cameo
business I hope he's flourishing and
it's not it's not him it's us that line
was great he goes it's not it's not us
he was I think he was enjoying it I I
think he's on board how weird is it that
we could just pay yeah cameo trips me
out I was looking for an artist to get
you a special message the knife was
scrolling through and I saw mark McGrath
and I was like oh my god no that's great
that's the best one you could got you
know he puts a lot of effort into I'm
very happy with marks service you
provide it to us but after two long
years it's been a solid ride we've
enjoyed having you but as Mark said
we're gonna have to let you go this is
it okay well bye everyone
well you have to stay to the end of
episode let's see this is so crazy that
oh he's got a new shirt on today that
you can see other people's hey what is
up Dianna
it's mark McGrath from the band sugar
ray off the charts how many things a
David always in your heart he did five
yesterday better same shirt on Chris
that's pretty good he made 500 back
yesterday
hey yeah he got back to me cool wet - it
was like the next morning I ordered at
like 3:00 a.m. and got the right back to
me dude it's kind of his full-time job
right now I guess so come on Dan yeah
after all he did for us well okay let's
read let's continue forth so
congratulate I was just excited for that
I want to end this
now that was all I cared about well
guess amazing we're gonna have to upload
that straight to the highlights Channel
just the video McGrath fires and Spotify
honored us this year the podcasting go
to Spotify and subscribe to the h3
podcast it helps the show a lot and it
makes me feel really good about myself
it's been a big year maybe a let's see
what's the stats h3 podcast number one
Vsauce was number one episode that kind
of surprised me but I think it's just
because it was old it was the first
episode of the year mm-hmm so you think
people were stoked was we were back from
break it was a big guest and it's had
the most time to gather views what about
that Delphine farts off Shane Dawson huh
some good headlines in there I suppose
guys get on over to Spotify and even if
you don't listen they're just subscribe
because it it makes me feel good and
what and don't I do so much for you
right I mean and I out here hustling
every day so just go subscribe we had
huge growth and followers how many
followers we have on Spotify Duran I
love the graphics mm-hmm we're looking
good folks we have a huge huge increase
in followers only four percent increase
in listeners that's what I'm talking
about that's because they're doing
exactly what I just said just go
subscribe you don't have to listen there
oh your words crossed borders from
Monaco to New Zealand you connect with
vans in 77 countries how many countries
are there to what yeah where's the other
one there's liking to 30 perhaps who's
not listening
because they don't speak English well
there might be a detriment someone in
there's got to speak English like
Madagascar there's gotta be one
[ __ ] in there listening ministry
podcast Antarctica there's some
scientists like here right here we
should be listening there could be
although monaco is pretty impressive
what are they doing monaco racecars okay
oh [ __ ] close it i raged closed it oh my
god oh my god let's just okay I'm over
it it takes too long YouTube rewind
that's what everybody wants to talk
about so let's just talk about it did
everyone see it you didn't yell I
haven't seen it did you guys all see it
back there yeah well I guess let's just
watch it right off the bat that's
because EO hasn't seen it let's all get
on the same page and let's discuss but
what I will tell you right off the bat
is that it has about a thirty percent
like ratio so that's 1.7 million up to
3.5 million down now what I will say is
that's a lot better than last year
YouTube had like a 1% like last year I
think that that this is progress I think
they should be happy about 30% likes I
like how it's always number one trending
like well to be fair it does have 28
million do they like did they goof it
yeah yeah they also run ads this is the
word to say I got an ad for it last
night on my homepage but it was an ad
for the trailer so to click the ad go to
the trailer there was only 30 seconds
and then click the trailer too I was
like what are you guys doing you don't
even know to run ads on your own
platform so so we're still using sound
bites from the last one that's true
that's true and I yeah well you'll see
you'll see I'll show to you a long has
it been exactly a year do they do it at
the say every year yeah eight I think so
pretty much December mid December
it's not mid though it's the sixth all
right I'm tired it's Friday
I'm so tired all the time I don't
understand I was we only live like it's
only like a 40-minute drive here I'm
falling asleep in 14 minutes I'm like
bro I have some kind of disease I think
I'm like epilepsy some kind of epilepsy
because it makes you tired and when I
Drive I have this like a serious
condition where I just get so sleepy
sometimes that it's scary I do wonder if
it's a condition I've never heard of it
no no we'll explain it if it's not
because when I step out the car I'm
relatively fine it's just in the car
it's like oh my body's like okay now
you're in peril I'm gonna make you
select you're just got anesthesia I had
another friend that had it so that's why
I do wonder if it's something they also
would just immediately get sleepy when
they were driving not immediately but
when they do it's like you can't keep
your eyes open that's crushing dude well
this was only a 10 minute drive and I
was already falling asleep anyway that's
neither here nor there Allah enjoy the
show this I cannot guarantee I won't not
pause it's five and a half minutes guys
so we're gonna have a lot to unpack here
okay here we go without further ado
without more preamble without further
conversation or talk we've discussed
everything and we are ready to click the
play button so when you are ready Allah
I will engage the clip up playback
are you prepared countdown three two are
you ready are you ready for the one say
confirm confirm that you're ready for
one one one and one zero zero time it's
launch time
oh I'm in it by the way that is so
awkward to watch YouTube rewind 2008 I
don't like that I'm in high school yeah
I don't like that I'm right next to rice
gum and by the way I don't like that I'm
just like portray to some hater ass
thank you jack I'm just some hater ass
awkward to watch youtube rewind my rice
come he's not even making an expression
why do they include him he's just doing
this like it's there's no expression
there why include rice um
did anyone call him rice come but don't
they just make me look like a hater
you
yes yes yes yes yes yes justice issues
just yes we can't play the music better
editor but to get there I gotta muted
it's just whatever you don't need audio
so what are they showing their likes to
eat your video has I think that yeah
exactly they're just gonna show the most
liked did we already get [ __ ] whatever
I'll tell them to screw off I played it
for a second YouTube needs to when
YouTube does this okay I've got a
problem already when they license this
music for this video they need to say
when you match in this video you don't
get to claim this [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying this is know our creators get to
react to this everybody they want
everyone to talk about it should I talk
about that email I got they sent me the
most and I had an aneurysm they send me
email about about said they're trying to
promote rewind I did I want to read it
it's the dumbest [ __ ] I ever heard they
called it
Sopranos it called surprising delight
anything they go yo we want to do a
surprise and delight so when you post
about rewind just use hashtag call to
action rewind and we'll do a surprise
and delight and I was like and so it
turns out they said so but I was able to
parse through it Ethan responded just
one word what question Martin I
shouldn't know but I just said what and
he goes oh sorry for the confusion and
they gave me another explanation didn't
make any sense so what I par through it
was that if I am tweeting about YouTube
rewind and I asked
I need that pose a call to action
question to my fans like what was your
favorite part of rewind hashtag YouTube
rewind and then what people respond to
me and use the hashtag they'll get a
surprise and a delight
someone from YouTube will randomly
select people that respond to me to give
them way for it a fanny pack
on teespring I get to just do some
random [ __ ] fanny pack that I get to
write something on it and it's like just
like it's a surprise and a delight I
said they should put inside turkish
delights meta this is the word delight
surprise and delight for a gift no but
it's just some shitty teespring fanny
pack and it has like a picture of
youtube rewind and it's just like I get
like three words to write on it be best
dude can you imagine me doing that you
want a fanny pack no you want a surprise
you want a surprise and delight that
means they have a whole team that's is
spending so much time on this stupid
campaign yeah because when I the guy who
emailed me I was like you know okay just
talk with the team and I got more
clarity I was like bro what I guess I
got a surprise and delight for you here
a girl
I feel like big they don't big and funny
reward it sounds like a translation from
Chinese surprise and delight it sounds
like a package at a massage parlor
yeah that's a that's what I will not
call a fanny pack and delight it's a
surprise but a lot of things are
surprises aren't necessarily good I'd
say half of all surprises are bad but
this one happens to be a delight if
there were turkish delights in it then
it'd be down are they sealed or they
just raw in the yeah that's not good
anyway I'm pissed too they they kind of
made me look like a hater [ __ ] and why
they even put rice gum you know what I'm
saying laughter we hated on them right
now
pissed at what at YouTube for portraying
you as a hater because they put rice gum
the ultimate hater [ __ ] but also we
didn't hear at least I made an
interesting facial expression rice comes
literally doing this like you could take
that from any video from any creator
this is what he did like what's the
worst what why we've got a hater [ __ ]
yeah there let's look at this great
frame of rice come they used I did it oh
yeah I have to meet it ready Wow do you
see that interesting expression I made
did you see that interesting and fun in
that my expression was a surprise and
delight what is rice come doing right
now you could do that about anything
Who am I right now
rice calm rice calm in my [ __ ] ass
[Laughter]
okay in 2018 we made something you
didn't like so in 2019 let's see what
you did like because you're better at
this than us I feel like that's an abuse
what you would say an abusive
relationship like they're so desperate
to be like you're better at this than us
all right so here they're just tallying
the likes I don't know you know whatever
it's all raw
maybe it's real Tati eating a shoe
this is awkward without sound we're just
staring yeah only mm-hmm but okay that's
what they that's what YouTube chose to
make us do so you made these the most
likes creator videos so here you go ten
Shane Dawson so some Russian [ __ ]
so they're just counting down the most
like videos of the year James Charles
and they were saying that that it's just
like a WatchMojo video which is true
they were just saying it's a boring and
a WatchMojo video yeah Wow Meester beats
number one yep
11 million they're showing musicians now
did they explain the most liked music
videos all righty t-series
I don't congratulations then j-hope I've
no idea who that is
dandy little Dickie bro how do people
like that that's crazy to me that people
like this video that was like the worst
song a video of the century didn't we
all agree on that it was like so corny
bro and yeah it had everyone right right
I guess that's why it got us in my life
hmm yeah but I didn't think anyone
actually liked that song it was like a
tech catastrophe well this this
countdown isn't like this is just views
no no it's likes look now it's like okay
yeah that has more views yeah golly
excuse my profanity ariana grande well
man oh did you just put in some music
sac BTS I don't get the BTS thing I'm
just gonna say it right now I don't like
k-pop
do you have an insight on k-pop Ian do
like k-pop what do you think about BTS I
mean I don't like it but I mean it's
just pop I don't know I just pop music
you like pop you're easy
I don't know I don't like the kind of
the blend they do of like hip-hop and
then like and really not that
interesting pop music I don't know I but
I I see why people like that but do
people like it ironically no because
that's what I thought
no do people are crazy on Twitter the
kpop fans they well it's so weird all
they do is post a gif of their favorite
like kpop person dancing and they go
[ __ ] crazy like I'm pretty sure that
somebody's gonna try to assassinate me
assassin made me like everybody's into
this kpop phenomenon and I I don't know
it's like I know that like Harley plays
is in the kpop Harley morally I think
PewDiePie's into kpop I know that Ian is
a huge kpop fan no no but I get it
I get why people like I don't know it's
like one direction or any of that stuff
I always hated but like why would
somebody like Harley like one direction
it's a great question you know or
PewDiePie and I might be talking out of
turn here but I'm pretty sure PewDiePie
likes kpop not just ironically no that's
what you don't want listen to music
ironically maybe how do you listen to
music ironically you're at home by
yourself we're watching Temptation
Island that's not ironic you're enjoying
you you can't hate music look you cannot
hate listen to music they call it like
guilty pleasures or whatever but they
actually just like it they like it yeah
like I like Third Eye Blind I know it's
like I know it's gay as [ __ ] for lack of
a better word but I like it
and so it's embarrassing it's you know
what I mean like sometimes I'll put that
[ __ ] on and I know every word on that
whole self-titled album
that's a ela ela
hater that goofs on me she makes me feel
like a little [ __ ] when I listen it
there it's some dork yes but I know it's
corny and I like it so that's what it is
I like it let's continue let's see I've
used the gay word garage derogatorily a
couple times
Doralee derogatorily and I've said uh-oh
you just cancel this show my show yeah
what can you do to me I've already said
the n-word look UK you can't take me to
hell well I've already said the n-word
live let's not invite touch me scene
every time did we start over the show's
over
do you want to get through this because
we're actually pretty much at breaktime
well let's go to breakdown we'll come
back we'll pick up what a mess they're
just gonna take us like an hour to
finish this you kidding me at this pace
let's go to break we'll be right back
you guys don't go away I'm gonna say ton
of racist stuff you're not gonna miss it
your jaw is gonna drop you bug did he
really say that and I'll be like yeah
there's a cold open back though dan said
mmm that does make complicate things but
what can you do we got a we got to go to
the copy because I we've got to talk
through this we have a cold open because
there's a car Kelly story I wanted to
come back and do a little RC car Kelly's
going too much of the sausage-making yes
- well what I gotta go to break there's
gonna take forever to get through this
we can't go to break just cut it all
right it is quick time you know about
quip is the electric toothbrush that is
changing the world and the landscape of
your mouth it's got soft bristles and a
vibrating tube here's that here let me
equip it's a little tube you click the
button and vibrates okay we're not done
it's got a little battery
so energy fishing it doesn't plug in to
do anything it just chills okay awesome
what's next
it's got soft bristles don't damage your
gums wow that sounds too good to be true
it's not let me tell you the thing about
clip is that it vibrates you turn it on
it times out a two minute perfect two
minute brush and every 30 seconds it
pulsates to let you know to move on to
the next quadrant to make sure you're
getting the perfect denim and dental
dentist recommended brush it's genius
Oprah put it on her oh god damn list and
that ain't easy to get on you know what
I'm saying yeah it's on my it's on my
list I've got my own list Oprah
[ __ ] you Oprah it's on my list equip is
awesome I love qyp is the only
toothbrush i use i swear to god it's
revolutionary you got three million
mouths using quip it's incredible it's
beautiful they've got floss dispenser
with premark strings to help you get
enough it's got it all and if you get if
you go to get quick calm /h through
right now you'll get your first refill
for free so go to you'll get your first
refill free at get quick calm /hre
that's GE t qu i p.com slash h3 quip
it's the good habits company to make
sure that mouth stay beautiful and clean
boy
and I want something else to get me
through this get me through this albums
of the year mega hits every track only
for [ __ ] you don't understand me put
the past away I wish you would step back
from the like yes you hear them all
singing along Zack do you like it I
actually know the drummer for that band
really by family friend cool I like it
is he doing well yeah yeah I worry about
them
Ian oh is he on candy or anything are
you serious I like it I like it I like
it I like it I like it
well maybe I don't even know the song
yeah if you grew up with it it was it
was ubiquitous when we were growing up
it was on the radio constantly
like lime and either won't stop me from
listen to my gay stuff baby I love third
line and I will take a dick in my all
right I apologize real quick for saying
gay yeah can we get the podium out time
we don't have time for that I should
know I apologize to my gay friends
apologies to the gays is that gay that
ours at home is that bong that I called
them the gays yes so watch how should I
refer to them because it feels wrong the
gays the homosexuals homology community
the homo sounds really bad the homos but
that's just short for homosexuality so
the homos so I mean how do I apologize
just how do I reference them don't refer
the gay community okay
just if you could please but the game
what can I say gay community but not the
gays it just sounds bad call that
entertaining all right let's get back
you say you cut all that and now we'll
get to this part here we were watching a
YouTube rewind pulled you to the gays do
you guys know this Shawn Mendes Camila
Cabello song no no yeah me neither it's
the number ones don't they have like a
romance so I think all the little girls
are scenery bad scene or eat
and in just confirm they have there
they're madly in love oh really
I don't know that's not actually what he
said oh thank you that oh that's that
was number so basically what the [ __ ]
what are we looking at now they kind of
switch gears just videos oh yeah I think
dance get their own category
what about hater ass [ __ ] videos
where's my category my opinion if you
want to hear it
okay I'll pause always for that I don't
like it it sucks okay well let's keep
watching we'll have that conversation
most watched video games
robot robot the [ __ ]
gert what the hell what is that I don't
know
Verena free city that should just be a
game around he's sick for tonight
minecraft is still number one that is
actually super interesting you know what
dude I've look at these gamers all they
do you keep the music going
it pumps me up Zach all they do is they
upload like 10 videos a day that doesn't
get that many views they just play video
games like chop a hour-long video into
ten parts and each one gets 300,000
views but somehow they all are getting
like a trillion yeah but that's what I'm
saying I should be a gamer I just make a
channel I'll fire all these guys and
already fired I'll do Ethan plays and
I'll just play [ __ ] video games all
day and you don't even need to be
entertaining I'll just sit there like
rice gum you have to be good though good
at roblox that's stupid good at roblox
you think I need to be good at roblox to
make a gaming channel really what about
you we've tried we've tried streaming
ourself gaming and first of all you can
help by try to entertain like you do I
remember you can't even focus on the cup
and then people don't really want to
watch someone mediocre that's why mmm
used to do puff gee I remember yeah
ultimately there's there's only so much
entertainment value pretty much after 10
minutes of streaming it all becomes
about what you want to order to you fun
to me sounds good to me
and then okay let's watch most like
beauty videos why why do the beauty
videos get their own cat what about
podcast
what about hater ass [ __ ] podcast oh
just mark ass painter ass [ __ ] podcast
so this big [ __ ] guys nobody cares about
podcast but this is look this is why I
never liked what they put together
why is there no podcast
why is there no hater ass [ __ ] podcast
oh so I have you nobody watches podcast
why would be number one one number one
one [ __ ] you Dan who's that guy why is
that guy so old
well I'm gonna go back is this old [ __ ]
what is this category you helped these
new creators break out oh I see who is
this guy okay whatever
hi I'm Wow hi I'm it dude new subs I'm
sorry what I'm sorry I thought crusty
old dudes have been around and had a
good year making podcasts are also
haters number one South Korea boy like
the Asian get him with the rice comes
down but you made these the most viewed
creators okay I feel like they went from
super produced to like the laziest
option possible doubt that was what
everybody said why so late everyone was
good good thing that it was just like a
lot to put any effort into something
that just everybody's just gonna I guess
the problem is there's not really any
inherent entertainment
value here I kind of agree that they
shouldn't do this anymore because it's
stupid in the first place who cares
but how has a zeal and on this list
that's insane that's what I'm saying all
she does is look at like reddit pages
isn't that what the number one youtuber
does I don't know even what I mean me
you're talking about me number one in
the hearts like mark McGrath the Gian's
right though is that what PewDiePie does
there no because he watched the whole
thing
yeah there's no podcast so I'm good why
am i hating on as Yulin I should be
heading on PewDiePie by the same metric
that's a good point in a sexism we've
made those videos too
yeah feel like I this podcast is kind of
just yeah okay guys I get it you have to
play it on let's get the podium out all
right congratulations that a seal and
Fisher cool do you don't think I could
get good enough at for a night that was
a channel nope dude perfect breath dead
dead
David Ober Wow he's killing it jelly's
so this yeah a jelly pencil animation
Wow animations acted ah
Felipe ah
PewDiePie hey it's your boy with the
fist with the brofist that guy only want
one looks at reddit threads did
here comes the part that really
triggered everybody really else a female
artist in France that's a category yeah
Middle Eastern creator to hit 10 million
well why don't you ever get any credit
for being a middle Easterner creator or
a female your Middle Eastern creator
does she have ten million subs she had
like I mean well she didn't have ten we
have it now that German channel we I
think it said two million yeah but
you're maybe the first I don't know you
got nobody likes me yeah nobody likes me
so what tell me the part of trigger
people's I'm not repressor of the T
series the fact that they had any series
no problem thing that happened but
people were upset that they it would be
more [ __ ] up if they didn't even
mention it people that would like
there'd be like a link India would new
Pakistan or something over there just
because cuz they're at war don't like
each other they'd push them to nuclear
holocaust okay so so thoughts go ahead I
am super pissed that there is no podcast
category and I'm not even kidding
well great people right now doing
podcast on YouTube like all of our
comedian friends that's true
and ourselves that's true what the hell
that's it the female creator in France
yeah that like all of the greatest
comedians right now doing podcasts on
YouTube mmm
preach it well Joe Rogan is a phenomenon
on YouTube oh yeah where is Joe Rogan
yeah I don't know why that's why I don't
like them though it's like they have
this they have this like specific point
of view on what YouTube is and then it
always is just portrayed in different
ways but you can see what they see
YouTube to be and they just completely
ignore whatever else is going on so do
you think that it deserves could the 33%
like ratio yeah would you like or
dislike
this video I don't like or dislike
anything I liked it because well I'm
gonna be honest with you I saw a sneak
peek of this through our friend at
YouTube and I I told him I thought that
people would like it I showed it to me
so I feel like I steered him wrong
you'll see because their thing was like
last year was a disaster everybody hated
it and this year we're just gonna keep
it vanilla and I think part of the story
or the story is that the rewind back
back back in the day used to just be
videos like this know which ones we like
the old ones they're really cool huh no
no no back back back back in the day how
much back Missy YouTube rewind
I saw people discussing this the thing
it was like 2013 2014 rewinds were done
in this in what fashion of this mmm no
maybe was maybe right yeah this was this
was like the golden years I think it's
like YouTube rewind 2008 did yeah
all right this isn't bra
bye bye bye bye bye bye here this one's
kind of a mojo WatchMojo bro presented
by rebecca black 11 million views but
this is on YouTube's official channel
this is legal dislikes on that one - oh
wait I think people went back in time
and like did Rebecca Black hosted that's
so epic breath yeah yeah you see it's
just a mega comp so people were telling
you to go back to your roots and they're
like oh let's go back to well I may not
have as much of a problem with it if
they include us us and others not me but
Joe Rogan like they're just gonna ignore
that
well the biggest podcast to be fair they
did honor French female comedians yeah
so let's see what Joe's biggest video of
the year was Doody yet he had a long
fuse with Elon Musk that was like
any Sanders that was that wasn't last
year that was I was lunch are you I was
freaking kidding me there's a Rogen
muscling yeah that was last year
I'm gonna be dead soon September 2018 no
way dude [ __ ] die of old age I cannot
believe it doesn't matter every episode
is huge on his toe that's why they
didn't acknowledge what's the top one
top viewed of this year is his Alex
Jones interview well that was well they
allowed it Edward Snowden that's a
little political Bernie Sanders that's a
little political Mike Tyson convicted
right that's the problem Bob Lazar a
little kiss spirit you got a problem
Kevin Hart can argue there but either
you just pick your route here you're
either gonna allow and acknowledge
everyone that's on that she's on the
platform or just don't even allow it if
you got a problem with it why'd they let
him have Alex Jones
I don't know but wait we're talking
about rewind yeah I'm asking why did
they know I lose something as big as the
Joe Rogan Park I'm with you I'm with you
girlfriend thousand times yes hundred
million times thousand times yes that
being said I do feel guilty because I
gave him the green light I said I'm sure
people are gonna love all your fault it
is
I don't you shoulda showed it to me
because I was like I was like dude it's
good it's fine people will like it
because it's like just basic cuz I'm a
direct response it's got PewDiePie in it
you know it's no data people can't argue
with the stats but again I guess people
just said it was boring and I see that
because they've they've built up this
crazy expectation for these things
and then people were saying stuff like
oh well at least during the Will Smith
one it was all me mobile I prefer Will
Smith but but then it's like well that
is true we all
they can't listen through the hey that's
true they had just have to keep it corny
yeah brace that they shouldn't try to
please us no that's just the word that's
like you can't listen to the haters me
anyone last you to the the hate on the
one last year not that it wasn't cringy
it was but it was a surprise to me
because I've Oh all of them have always
been that cringey I
I know people disagree they say that the
previous ones were better I go back and
watch them like they're just like the
one from last year I saw a few ones that
I thought were good kpop I don't know
that was a pretty precious moment I mean
yeah that's better than this it is
better because people more thought I
mean like you said we're still using
those sound bites to this day but the
thing is like if your YouTube the
comments are so brutal
it's like headlines the worst there's
just like video of all time welcome to
YouTube YouTube just embrace it be that
get will scan if they want to be on
YouTube mmm
welcome to the game the hate is all
around you do you know what's the thread
that shows the fabric of YouTube
together hey that's true it's so funny
that like YouTube is on YouTube right
big that that was the crucial changing
point is now that there's this team who
are on YouTube they can't realize how
much hate oh how hard it is right and
they've got their own complexes about
that's not fair they're just haters
[Laughter]
start tweaking algorithm to favor their
[ __ ] I want to make a gaming channel so
bad dude don't h3 and BR I just want to
make 10 videos a day and game and I want
the game I want to be a gamer
no there's no way that's what you wrote
people just want to watch me game what
do I have to do to get on this list for
real see I was only introduced as a
Harris [ __ ] right I have a problem I
wouldn't be on the list I have a problem
that how did you not show me the preview
you were not there and it was just I
didn't you know we're busy people you
know you know I have a lot of criticism
it was us he had to do it on whenever
they do something private they do it on
a call so that you can't rip it off
share it so they share screens and show
- yeah
I thought it was okay I did I thought it
was okay I thought people were hating a
little too bit much I understand they're
like an abusive spouse they've been
through a lot you know and they're
trying to recover it was underwhelming I
agree I think that I was portrayed as a
hater [ __ ] I think rice gums channel
should be erased
banished why are they honoring rice come
as a hater [ __ ] he's like he's the
hater [ __ ] they hate her [ __ ] hate
on you know what I mean [ __ ] that kid
girl I'll box Bryce come do you think I
could beat rice coming to boxing match I
thought you were saying you're gonna box
I'll put him in a box box and ship him
24 hours ocean challenge do you think I
could take rice come in a boxing match
yes or no he's a pretty guy and he's a
little bit I felt like I could take
there you go
tag-team is ass he has a massive penis
this is my okay I'm gonna complain
because you guys will do it a lot more
different I'm not actually talking wait
what is going on
why did Ian comment on rice comes penis
I don't know what to think anymore do
you think I think I could take rice come
on a boxing match
he's such a little [ __ ] he looks like
Gumby like I said you don't start [ __ ]
with rice gum all of a sudden watch I
think dude that's like the b-list
what if I just train my heart out and I
came out jacked I just [ __ ] broke him
over my leg I got dragged you invited me
he's a coward
hater [ __ ] I'm pissed I YouTube did
they put him in there embarrassing
did they not show you that part look
what am I gonna say take rice come out
yeah I didn't say that
it made me sign something to say people
were saying oh we should claimed their
video but what about me they didn't come
from my opinion that's what they got
that's why you should claim their video
you keep ignoring me throw would that be
so happy away 30 miles that'd be so
awesome
are they not a female I think you're
classified as a transgender school did
okay well how long have been going cuz
I'm not even to the second story
[Laughter]
we're just a little under an hour
doesn't they like at the top of the
first page yeah did you get your
passports did you I sure balls we got
talking about Papa in the house Papa's
in the house well you wanna do the let's
talk about PJ they're talking start
talking about Papa and I'll set us up
for the Arkell
story that how did they both work okay
Papa John speaks we need your laptop for
this I don't know it's happening okay
I'll start with a brief recap I think he
just wants to do that work elephant Papa
John Instagram page we weren't sure if
it's real or not that's what you said to
do nothing's ready what did you have to
do to get ready you got to turn on the
mics and my mics on because I thought we
would do cold-open into our Kelly just
to distract the people I'm so glad this
is all on video I'm not crazy it's not
ice it's you we had a our Kelly bit I
know you after the break I wanted to get
stay on track but we could talk about
pop I mean it's totally out of order I
don't stop it's right next Papa John
speaks ok think get yourself together
now bring it down Papa John speaks stay
tuned keep it together last I just want
to be a gamer so bad even you're in the
pizza category you're not in the gaming
category it's true I'm an acoustic
category he has no pizza those cheese
sticks that Trisha is eating in the last
episode and we just they were good but
they're coated in sugar that surprised
the hell I didn't like that about it
it's so dirty I ate two of them I feel
like puking just had to buy like
I like it I like it I like it I like it
I like it I'm just I don't know what's
going on did Papa John Pappajohn okay so
I'd something slowing down today to
cheese sticks coated in sugar that ain't
good for you bro I'll tell you right now
no to anyone that's imagining a cheese
stick it's like no it's a cheese like
corn baseball bat oh yeah so Papa John a
fan sent us Papa John what seemed to be
Papa John's personal Instagram account
and it seemed way too far to be too far
too good to be true
uh-huh I engaged in let's see he posted
a story do we have these yes it's me but
we even made it know he posted my memes
is that in here yesterday
did you put it in a video uh like I
requested it's in a video yes because it
just is linking to Angie's stories yes
it's what it doesn't work if you're not
logged in Oh so Zach when I asked to put
it in a video wait what do you I was off
the headset for a second what do you
jack where are the video we ripped them
we ripped them they're all where are
they where is there was a link to it
that's all in there you blew up this
week there bro what I can't hear you in
the office anymore wait for real yeah
all I see is Instagram links do you see
my document yes okay that blew out the
speaker the sound guy blew out the
speaker Zach when you rip the glue just
say when you rip videos you have to put
them in my document otherwise how am I
gonna look at the rips can't hear you
guys cuz Zach blow up the speaker when
he was yelling at me I didn't you can't
even hear me now what is this nobody's
helping us there was just sitting here
in the trenches everybody's madness at
its optimum in the dark
you just didn't copy it over we can hear
you know say something
Zach hello hello you blow out the
speaker hello hello hello yeah you guys
can you guys can where is it it's not at
the top
I see migos got their own Popeye dish I
see Zach just posts it to me in discord
or something okay okay thanks for thanks
for nothing these guys I'm telling you
this is the worst show we've ever done
I say that every episode but this is
certainly it so anyway let's start here
I sent him the unsliced pizza now was
announced today the idea right that was
your genius idea and they get to him
absolutely it did that's I was messaging
him and there was no response and then I
sent the unsliced pie and then all of a
sudden
who's this Pappas in the house hey Ethan
thanks for reaching out this definitely
sounds like something I could do
unfortunately appears you're right no
reason for a piece of beasts left left
unsliced rookie move where's your show
based out of they asked they I think
it's a PR firm I might be papa but it's
probably I know it's I know it's
connected with Papa now it was announced
today that Papa John is divorcing his
his longtime wife and I asked myself my
heart breaks for him yeah she's
divorcing him accurate I asked myself
what hurt his heart more his wife coming
to him with divorce papers or this
unsliced pizza that's the tough one both
on the same day I mean the man my man is
liable to uh you know he must be having
such a hard time hopefully he's got his
son his helpers best friend Bo with them
to help them do bro Zack I put it in
Disco why there's so many of them I see
it like five videos video all right I
thought you guys cut them in two
different links no why are you spam
chatting us then why you spanic check to
make sure that you saw it such a man who
go
ah so this is from Papa John's Instagram
yes okay Papa John Shetty's defense we
have gotten Papa John's since he was
ousted and it's not as good I swear I
wasn't even slight wasn't even cut the
pizza sucked it was like a f tear when
Papa John was in office with Bo in the
house that Pizza wouldn't an a every
time sometimes SS that that's not
related to our story be a great day so
this is a response I said Papa you need
to make an Instagram video saying this
is really your account nobody buys it
because we were afraid that we're being
trolled it was something but here's the
thing it was at eight o'clock was that
five o'clock Pacific time and it was
already pitch black outside because of
the winter and daylight savings he's on
the East Coast I think it was eight
o'clock over there
so it's later and presumably darker
right so what he sent me was a video of
him at late afternoon it's still light
out so I was wondering but maybe he's
somewhere else I don't know he's in um
uh I was reading an article today he's
in up Louisiana or some [ __ ] like that
Kentucky Kentucky you know it's funny
they said he lives in like a nine
million dollar mansion in Kentucky and
it's the most expensive house in the
city who lives in a Louisville or
something that's a starter house no they
come and this finally started anyway God
get it together middle Kent from here
it's all your laptop and we need you
Ethan this is one another cheese don't
have any ever knowing salts in
always okay so Papa John's sent me these
videos in response to me asking him to
verify his account didn't quite satisfy
me because I said asked him to say yes
this is really my account what he did
say is I made an Instagram account so
while it's not a hundred percent
confirmed its him it I don't see any
other Instagram account that is on seven
percent I would say ninety yeah at least
ninety seven on Twitter could be a great
day to start a new Instagram account
like I shared in the recent interview
there's some serious problems going on
with Papa John's when I founded the
company I had two fundamental principles
make a great pizza and take care of your
people I'm concerned about the pizza and
I'm really really concerned about Papa
John employees and franchisees yeah all
right to set the record straight yes I
inspected 40 pizzas in 30 days actually
a few more but I'm hearing these things
that the product has changed and there's
passionate about quality as I am you
gotta check these things out right I did
oh by the way I don't just sweat garlic
butter it's in my blood yes it's me now
I have a feeling the PR team is running
this it's way too slick of an operation
they cut the clip from the podcast like
an hour after I talked to them
there's no way Papa John's that slick
unless Beau's with them cuz beau is high
tech low pizza and Papa's hide he's a
low tech if you recall yeah but what is
great is that it seems if I can just oh
this is the most recent conversation is
that they may be interested in a Skype
interview having Papa John callin to our
show the h3 podcaster greatest show ever
to defend himself set the record
straight and talk about the pizza the
people and the ingredients here on the
h3 podcast what do you think about that
I think that would be fantastic
fantastical fantastisch so we'll wait I
put him in touch with Dan we're waiting
for touchdown here yeah that was
[Laughter]
yeah you uh you told me you told them to
reach out to me yesterday right still
waiting on the email you just he is
getting a divorce
I know we will correct that news so I
feel like that might be a little bit of
a distraction such a rough year for Papa
first the unsliced pizza second the
divorce what's next
he's got this a lawsuit now oh he's
suing some ad agency so papa was ousted
because he said n-word on this
conference call and he's accusing this
marketing agency what was the name of
them laundry service laundry that sounds
like I'm so sketchy laundry take out the
laundry huh
they're fairly big so they were
apparently recording the call and then
the call got leaked of publications and
that's how this whole story below I
think beyond that they I think I was
claiming that they were the ones who
encouraged him to have this diversity
training call mmm he thinks it's a whole
setup he from his telling it was like a
whole conspiracy they like egged him on
into saying the n-word and then trying
to extort but if knowledge that is
knowledge and then leaked it oh and then
at asked for money to kill the story is
what he's saying oh they did that's not
believe he was saying that they said you
need to pay us six million dollars or
we're taking this recording to the press
that sounds unlikely if they're that big
of a firm this is this is straight from
Papa but I don't know
I'm not calling Papa a liar but that
actually the pizza conspiracy is a
fascinating one he hires this marketing
firm they urged him to do this diversity
training they record it without him
knowing he ends up goofing it are saying
the N word which they leaked the
publication's to get him fired talk
about Judas this sounds crazy I don't
know I'd love to learn more about the
pizza yeah I mean he's Julius Caesar
he's Julius little Caesar and CEO what
was the guy replaced in Bruno the guy
who replaced him
was his best friend well I don't he was
his picture yeah no well yeah I'm [ __ ]
up but the guy who replaced him as CEO
was his hand-picked option clothes
everything he was little Richie was
usurping the throne and he is he is a
brute oh he already left too and now we
got mr. Arby's and now we have Shaquille
O'Neal in charge he has no experience
he doesn't ain't gonna go from roast
beef to pizza I mean it's insane it's
like what am I gonna go run a science
Channel just because I have a YouTube
channel it doesn't mean I know how to
run a Science Channel you okay
you can't go from roast beef to pizza
it's a different category and soul in
the food industry it's a different
category of food I'm trying to tell you
I can't go run I couldn't go for example
run a makeup guru channel I'd like to
see that well maybe I'll go be a gamer
makeup hybrid here's a new toy I'm
reading an article that just came out
today about this lawsuit and I guess
he's now contending that the recording
proved that he himself never used that
word Wow I'd love to hear that he never
said the N word that would be super
scandalous if he never even said that N
word yeah yeah the claim stems from a
secret tape recording by a laundry
service in May of 2018 some details of
which appeared in the story in Forbes
falsely reporting that mr. Schneider
used a racial slur against African
Americans in truth during the conference
call mr. Schneider actually expressed
his disdain for racism and criticized a
well-known figure who reportedly used
racial slurs the recording of the call
proved Schnatter said that he himself
never used that word which contrasts
sharply with the false narrative
reported in force well wait I think he I
think we admitted to
saying the N word in context of saying
that he hates that word so I think he
said I hate that mmm me I want to hear
that accordion frankly yeah I mean I
guess that would prove it one way or
another this is intriguing but either
way I do feel like Papa got played dirty
because he would never set it with
malice he was only using it in reference
of I mean saying to people you can't use
that word like where's the line you
can't use the word in context of a
conversation about it okay can
Huckleberry Finn use the n-word people
started to removing the n-word out of
Huckleberry Finn Tom Sawyer it's a whole
thing I know people but I'm saying well
the person who wrote it was a real
person yeah I mean it's a conversation
about the word yeah but where do you
draw the line I get what you're saying
can we not use the word in a
conversation about the word it sounds
like we should not but I don't think
that he should lose everything because
of saying it in that context it's
important to yeah the context is
important because while I agree I think
that I've grown a lot of matured since
my last usage of the hem word on camera
like I don't know though combination of
things because he expressed having a
problem with people kneeling and then
this came out issues with the effort
with the blondie yes well I I see your
point because that doesn't look good in
context what if he but if he can prove
that he never actually said it well
that's how you stand or yeah I mean
that's that's because if I was trying to
frame Papa then I'd go after the racial
thing because people will have no
problem accepting that after the
kneeling thing which I I think he is
totally out of hand
yeah I think they should kneel they
should roll they should lay they Stewart
everything want I support the right to
kneel that's what America is all about
and now look at his feets assails he
complained that kneeling was hurting his
pizza sales now look at his pizza sales
no I got no sales big
I'm down they're sending out unsliced
pizzas she thought I'm saying it all
started from him trying to clown on the
kneelers I mean elan has a craved it
when his pizza was when his pizza
dynasty is tumble into this ocean like a
sand castle I got left her backstage
weren't you uh what can I say I mean I
love the guy well you know I love his
pizza I have fraud I have some problems
with this politics we're gonna work that
out here I'm not gonna lie to him and be
like you know the truth is I love the
pizza love to the pizza the man I
disagree with politically okay but
that's okay because I'm here to learn
the truth the true untold story of Papa
John shatter shatter not a natter natter
in that news report they kept calling
him not her not her they were saying it
a third way s'matter
when you Kirk when you cook up perfect
pizza and you take it out of the oven
you go natter like you know when you hit
a three-pointer like a Kobe mmm Kobe you
take the perfect pizza you go Schnatter
I think Papa it's better mmm doesn't
roll off the tongue the same Papa
I like Schnatter it's like Kobe two
syllables both have two syllables stay
tuned
yeah let's talk about Joe Biden I love
this one I swear to god I'm not racist
you guys I just think I've said like
10,000 racist things this episode but I
swear to you guys I'm not racist I don't
know racist bone in my body that's like
the most racist thing people say they go
I'm I don't have a racist bone in my
body that's how you know they're like
straight-up Klan members
uh Joe Biden got into it with some ioann
voter this was so bad man Joe is really
deteriorating he's just such an awful
candidate he's just too old man you
should just chill it out go ahead Joe
3 3 3 oh well watch this and tell me
what you guys think
an Iowa voter accuses former VP Joe
Biden of sending his son hunter to the
Ukraine to work for the energy company
that is so scandal and Joe snaps so
let's watch this confrontation by the
way just for the record this is the no
malarkey tour which may explain his
response to him well you asked this
question in the wrong town hall and by
the way doesn't know I'm well RQ makes
me think of tuna I kind of Larkin hmm I
can see that why it seems like a similar
word malarkey no like a can of tuna they
have another name for tuna uh Alba Alba
something Oh albacore albacore tuna
before malarkey why does it look like
Joe why does it look like Joe's leading
the bingo for the at the Retirement
Center look at his voters it did it
looks like this the future of America
there's a lot of white hair bro why does
it look like Joe is running for the
presidency at the low at the retirement
community
damn that average age in that room is
like 79 here we go
that's about them just dying up it's
really hard to understand anything but
you get that he goes you on the other
hand sent your son to Ukraine you get a
job in energy he had no experience in
order to get access to the president
you're doing the same thing he is high
the way that was a fad just called
vaping fad that's such a bad look you
know he goes that's why I'm not
sedentary he's saying I don't watch the
TV cuz you're fat sedentary means you
have a lifestyle like me essentially you
don't move around at all I love how the
guy has a mic but he's not even using it
yeah expressing him well to be fair it's
in a small classroom um Joe Biden has
this thing where he just has the same
way of talking and he's always like and
by the way number two number one number
two everyone you're fat number two I
never said that number three no malarkey
number four I'm not stand by the way how
does he get off calling this guy fat
that's so crazy
that's not is that into what no malarkey
means to joke I don't like it
so once again
why was he challenging to do push-ups
push-up cuz all those old people are
like [ __ ] I remember when I could do
push-ups
this guy's the king of old people he
could do a push-up who challenges anyone
to push-ups Jill Biden when he sees a
fat guy you can't lose that - this is
when a crowd verifying you goes horribly
wrong
cuz he gets all like yeah I'm tearing
this guy down but he now he just
straight-up called him fat that's not
true
everybody says that yeah I don't I mean
that's just not yes he died every day I
don't know just say it's not true but
people say it people say it of course
they do what are we talking about here
you know I'm saying I mean maybe the
specific thing that Joe got his son the
job isn't necessarily one of the
accusations but the fact that all the
rest of it and that his son had the job
with no experience to get access to the
president like all of that yeah lots of
people are saying so you think he's
specifically addressing that Joe got him
the job it's so muddled I mean he's he's
doing a terrible job if that I'm trying
to give I guess that makes sense but he
doesn't explain yeah he's got old brain
fart Wow
he knows no Pizza experience
[Music]
look fat what are you doing if you're
gonna if you're gonna insult someone for
being fat to at least be funny about it
look fat here's the deal Joe you know
all Americans are fat bro those fat
people in that room here dare to support
you
what's up you know you think that any of
these people can do push-ups Brau wait
got flex and all your senior citizens so
you drive anymore back on the truck well
I think you've totally failed dressed
with grace and he called him fat which
is awesome but not a good look I don't
know if he's like well Trump says he
grabs women by the [ __ ] and made fun of
like disabled reporter and all that
doesn't work for you
Trump is at least funny when he does it
so we're gonna say don't try and beat
him on the bully thing because he's
funny
he's good if you can make someone laugh
you can get away with anything well just
ask me I've said that n-word because you
speak I'll tell you what it's because uh
you just gotta own it you have to own it
don't be too proud of it I'm only I'm
not proud I'm deeply ashamed I don't get
the poly Mountain prove it to you right
now but I just think that um okay did I
need to bring it up as as frequently as
possible no you're right I'm not I don't
want to make it seem like I'm proud of
it I'm just trying to do a gag I know
you're trying to do a gag but I feel
like you gotta watch out sometimes may
not come off that way oh really okay
you're right but I think you're right
that uh I definitely don't want to come
off that way
so thank you for not thank you for
sparing the malarkey with me and being
straight you wanna watch the president
of Portugal breaking the necks of some
young kids excuse me
oh I didn't stutter so explain this clip
this is the president of Portugal
greeting a bunch of kids yeah let me go
back cuz check it out he's just grabbing
and the kid he saw so I had to go in the
comments because that only explanation
was pretty deep I guess in Portugal he
is famous for sticking it to Trump
because you know Trump is famous for
when he meets world leaders he Yanks in
our hand so the president of Portugal
went to the white and he yanked the [ __ ]
at a trump and I guess everyone in
Portugal was real proud of him for that
and he gets meme down there for being
the yanker so the kids will you see that
gave a good yank so now it's an honor to
be thanked and yeah because in Portugal
everyone's all happy that he yanked the
president so I guess yeah it's another
dick he gave him a good yank girl like
and you have to assume the Trump gave
him a Yank too and he got pulled almost
off the curb that's his classic move so
do this that's a good yank right there
by uh so by the way so that's what that
is but I saw this today now where since
we're on the topic of the prime minister
of Portugal enjoy this clip of the
president meeting the president just
drew he's meeting the president of China
China and he just starts droning dude
it's [ __ ] crazy well so embarrassing
for a guy I feel bad for him
at the same time it's quite gross
somebody said it's cuz he has dentures
or something that can make yeah I like
it and I don't like this man
so you want to are Kelly cuz it says
after the break are more memes about the
president of Portugal no only two only
two huh
do you expect that I would have more
just gonna open there be a third round
it out honestly are you have something
for me there president let's see if
there's anything for Dan president of
Portugal I don't think we've ever even
bought it in the country of Portugal
before today Portugal and we had to
Portugal French journalist first
Portuguese presidents what do we got the
u.s. election principle which is we
don't speak problems than other
countries mostly friendly countries can
ask you which delegation you're always
Portuguese Portuguese delegation yes and
your office I'm the president what an
idiot oh my god what an interview
[Music]
alright now we go there was three yeah
there you go
damn no respect for the president of
course is he a good guy they said that
he's beloved there because it seems like
a silly like in a good way
they say he's beloved and in Portugal
well I mean it takes us some kind of a
guy to to do this to kids and I mean
that I know good way look how he Yanks
the [ __ ] out of this kid watch this this
guy's a character dude look how I toss
them I love it I like it I like it I
like it I like it did you get your Pat
okay our Kelly we got our Kelly story so
I got to go do this thing are you ready
for your gag with our Kelly yes yes sure
we can be ready so are Kelly and turns
out that he used he bribed someone to
get Ali the singer a fake ID so they
could get married because she was 15 at
the time and he that's what Ethan yeah
what's going on did you get your shots
the girl to America America do you have
your passport did you get your shots
girl would you like to come back with
Rob to America
[Music]
get your bath box did you need your
shots
[Music]
to America
[Music]
[Music]
thank you everybody hurry America so the
idea was that that was gonna be a cold
open after the break that didn't happen
but here we are nonetheless okay what
why you giving what's with attitude
but did you want me to start explaining
the story when you walked out there no
okay cuz I thought that that's what you
were telling me to do the idea was that
like you gotta work in communication
well it it already wasn't good because
it was supposed to be a cold open but
that was already out of the question
well you didn't have to do anything
whatever you did was good okay you got
probably your talk about stuff no you
seem upset I started telling the story
and then it was kind of like a bump well
go ahead and continue I I don't you tell
the story now that you're here are Kelly
was charged for bribery in the case of
alia who he married when she was a mere
15 years old
many people wondered that how was it
possible that he was able to Wed a 15
year old and that is a good question it
turns out he bribed a government
employee in 1994 so that he could obtain
a fake ID for the singer alia a person
familiar with the matter said what a
creep man goes creeping it up and he was
27 at the time she was 15
have you seen a 15 year old girl man
they are not I mean that daddy right
dude 15 that's one year away from 14
that's really not right a persistent
question has dogged are Kelly's two
decade music career how was he able to
legally marry the singer Aaliyah when
she was only 15 years old so it turns
out he bribed government officials and
obtained a fake ID that made it look
like she was 18 the new allegations
expand on the existing racketeering
indictment filed in New York against
r.kelly accusing him of sexually
underage girls and coercing them into
illegal sexual activity
he's been criminally charged as we know
[Music]
criminal activity from 1994 would
normally fall outside the statute of
limitation preventing prosecutors from
filing charges for the fourth at trial
in 2019 but the broad racketeering
charges mr. Kelley faces in Brooklyn
where he is accused of leading a
criminal enterprise that that recruited
his fans which we just saw evidence of
mm-hmm sometimes underage girls to have
sex with them allows prosecutors to
introduce acts from any time period that
were part of the alleged conspiracy the
statute has typically been used to take
down mob organizations the brooklyn
indictment which was originally filed in
june also accuses mr. kelly of
kidnapping forced labor
failing to disclose a sexually
transmitted disease oh [ __ ] that's a
crime that's it whoa I didn't know that
that's crazy
two sexual partners and producing child
pornography feeling to disclose sexually
transmitted disease is the least of his
problems yeah did he so screw it all I
love that they can actually include
everything from yeah the racketeering
you're gonna have a sex crime don't do
it in Brooklyn I guess do it in Brooklyn
please do it in Brooklyn I do have one
more story for you ela that we can wrap
this up with now you know how you always
say that Subway sandwiches always taste
the same no matter what you put in it
well I may have an explanation for that
subway souza journalist for reporting
its chicken is only 50% chicken and
losses back in 2017 a team of reporters
from the Canadian broadcast corporation
sent samples of subway chicken along
with chicken from a and W McDonald's Tim
Hortons and Wendy's do a lab to test how
much of it was actually chicken most of
the tests came back showing between 88.5
and 89
for chicken DNA except for subway
Subway's oven roasted chicken tested as
53.6% chicken and the strip's 42.8%
chicken the rest with soy protein
perhaps they thought there had been a
mistake so they sent it again for
another test yet the results were the
same
subway predictably was not pleased they
followed a 210 million dollar defamation
suit claiming that the story was
reckless and maliciously published and
the study itself lacked scientific rigor
yet the court denied their or they lost
basically they lost that case so their
chicken is at best fifty three percent
might as well just be vegetarian isn't
that crazy
you know I've had those chicken patties
those ain't right that's that way those
are not right they're all like rubbery
so there you go Jared I wouldn't exactly
call that eating fresh would you I do
not like some way so I like it I don't
like it I like it I don't don't play it
again Zach I swear to God I'm mark
McGrath fire you
I'll get else so fast well that about
wraps her up should I sing him off with
the I think we should actually close
with this clip the one I have
highlighted scroll down a little bit you
wanna do this one
I mean it's so good Andrew yank friend
the show our favorite to win the
presidential candidate for the Democrats
having too much fun opening his new
headquarters
squirting whipped cream into someone's
mouth I don't know how this situation
even arose why does he have whipped
cream why does this guy want whipped
cream squirted in his mouth I think the
guy brought it yeah you probably brought
it yeah but like I mean that's a note
for me dog you know I mean like that's
theirs
only bad things about the squirtin and
but here you go
yang is down he's having a good time
[Music]
watch the campaign manager he's like oh
they break uh tit but the guy at the
campaign end is like dude anyway you go
yang Yang hanging hang on December 20th
after winning the next presidential
debate will be here on the HP pockets
the next president of the United States
Andrew yang giving everyone $1,000 why
are you laughing down you know Yang's
gonna win sure who do you thinks gonna
win wise guy
do you really want to know yes I do why
when asked Bernard Sanders Bernard I'm
down you know I ride or die for burn to
burn okay I mean that's just my opinion
you really feel it Burt wow that would
be incredible if Bernie actually won I
would love to see that by II will see
Elizabeth and Joe are gone is that who
you want oh who who you think will
actually win that's who I want okay what
do you think will win
yeah I'd say him answer so let's see
there's Elizabeth Warren she's out joe
sloppy joe is out PP judge I don't see
it he's out well I mean he's at the
moment the one that seems to have a lot
of momentum in Iowa but in the rest of
the country that matters all I was
seeing a poll Pete Budaj has 0% of black
vote that means there's not one black
dude they can find the supports people
judge I think long term that's gonna be
a big problem for him yeah but not
awesome not one black dude wants to vote
for him but yeah he has history just
some he's just like he looks like Howdy
Doody yes there's a big controversy in
the town that he's the mayor of yeah he
fired the police chief who was black at
the request of
of officers and then it turned into big
scandal because those officers ended up
being racist or something I don't know
all the details but it's definitely it's
hurt him there's a reason why he pulls
it I just thought it was because he
looked like the dude from Mad Magazine
at Trump yeah Alberti Newman that
probably doesn't help either but I think
that's probably less important I don't
think he's got a shot though he's just
too goofy looking yeah I mean I think if
he were the nominee it would probably
not go well for him he's also yeah I
mean he's the mayor of like the fourth
biggest town in [ __ ] what Indiana or
one I've been that big of a deal I think
he got into office like in his election
to be mayor with like 5,000 votes or
something hmm
wow that's a big step yeah go from that
to president it just seems like it's a
little but who does that was it come
come , was gone
so who's left you kind of named them all
yank and and and uh Tolson are still
seized technically lumbers not happening
well the sloppy joe I don't know
whatever we may sloppy joe I think is
most likely to get it still which is sad
I don't think sloppy joes got a shot in
hell he's he's polling high nationally
but I would it matters a lot more than I
think people realize because this this
is the way it goes every primary is
whoever wins Iowa all of a sudden the
narrative completely changes momentum
matters more than so we'll see we'll see
what happens once the pipe is know we'll
do a room for there I mean I want yang
Gor I'm being Bernie's a great one yang
Gor burn in Iowa it's a caucus which is
like you know different than a primary -
and I think in a caucus it kind of works
in a weird way where second choices
matter a lot - mm-hmm so that kind of
that factors into it a lot because you
know if somebody like Tulsi you know her
supporters probably second pick is
Bernie in most cases because you know
she campaigned for him and endorsed him
in the
selection oh I didn't know that so if
you don't get to a certain threshold in
a caucus then you go to your second
choice and so it gets a little bit more
complicated than just who's polling in
first what Bernie Sanders beat Donald
Trump I mean all of the tests he would I
actually think Bernie unlike a sloppy
joe and Elizabeth Warren
well sloppy joe maybe I don't know just
because people know him but he I think
there's a lot of Trump supporters that
would go feel the Bern mm-hmm yeah
there's a yeah when they do those kind
of you know hypothetical head-to-heads
against Trump usually Biden and Bernie
are the only two that consistently beat
Trump all the rest lose to try what
about yang game I don't know if nobody
didn't do it yeah I mean maybe it's been
done I bet my instinct would say that he
probably could be Trump because I think
yang also has a lot of crossover appeal
with I think yang would perform
extraordinarily well against Trump yeah
I think we gotta get him in there no
yank gang gang gang gang gang
[Music]
do you have your passports did you get
your shots the girl would you like to
come back with Rob to America or the
subway America did you had your
passports did you get your shots girl
would you like to come back with Rob to
America
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are over this song that make sense right
[Music]
we're still playing the whole time yeah
it's a good one
let's get along play the song and do the
sounds Zach and yella you know what I'm
talking about
[Music]
this is the official HTML I got I got it
girl was you active backward to America
I got America did you get your passports
did you get your shots girl would you
like to come with
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come over it dan you should end it all
right show is over
[Music]